I didn't know is this true you were
engaged Allison Mack
oh God see this is the great thing
about
rumors
this is all before all that [__]
happened this was like 14
2014-15 yeah so so you know so let me
take you back to just before Supergirl
um TMZ runs this whole information about
me and and that that you know I was
engaged to her while that Nexium stuff
was happening so I started getting all
these social media engaged to her uh
according to TMZ and so so I started
getting all of this social media
harassment really what do you know what
is Whitmore know what does he know were
you part of this is are your initial
some I mean like awful awful stuff
so I I contacted my publicity people I'm
like this has to be squashed because if
I'm anyone who's hiring people
um
they're not why would they want to deal
with this why would they want to deal
with all of this whether whether you
know and they're like well so you
weren't engaged I'm like I don't know
the chick I worked with her but you
never really knew her no no no no so
here's the deal the fans really liked
our relationship on the show so I was
aware that the fans were like we think
that they're actually dating in real
life and I'm like oh great they're
spreading rumors about that but whatever
okay fine then that that story took on a
life of its own and the fans then
decided oh not only are they dating they
just got engaged and I'm like what they
couldn't be further from the truth which
is such a [__] invasive thing when
people are making sure people said I've
dated look Michael's dating history and
it's girls I've never heard of yeah
never heard of a lot of them yeah
Candace I was happy about Vampire
Diaries you said I dated this girl
Candace um who is great she's great in
the show we went on two dates or
something yeah we had a great time she
was awesome that was it now you were
Avenged you were engaged to her that's
never yeah never engaged in anybody
illegitimate child let me ask you so but
really quick so so dude I thought I had
my public publicity team write TMZ and
essentially say hi you didn't do your
due diligence this is going to harm
Sam's ability to get work and if you
can't provide one [__] photograph of
these two people in public retract your
goddamn story or we're gonna show you
and TMZ
then suddenly started issuing
retractions and then the little sites
issued retractions and within two weeks
I was hired for Supergirl and I remember
being like guys good thing we did that
because if this story because it was
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and it's not because they would
have believed it they would have been
like that's too much
we did it or not let's not deal with the
drama yeah